quitting your six-figure income to
become a full-time youtuber that's
exactly what rob from rob built did and
i can't wait for you to hear this entire
episode
hey welcome to the youtube made simple
show my name is heather torres author of
the upcoming book youtube made simple
and host of this show right here on
youtube so if you are interested in
hearing conversations with youtubers who
made it simple and figured out a way to
go become full-time at this then make
sure you subscribe to this show we're
going to jump into today's interview
with rob builds now rob was on a
previous episode but let me give you a
little introduction rob started his
youtube channel in march of 2020. he had
been doing short-term rentals airbnbs on
the side of his six-figure income he
actually was able to grow his side
business his youtube channel as well as
his real estate portfolio and he
recently quit his job to become a
full-time content creator and real
estate investor this is so cool and i
can't wait for you to jump into this
episode where we talk about how he did
it how he decided to move into this
season and how he was able to grow his
youtube channel to over 125 000
subscribers in just over a year this is
a great episode that you want to be
locked into so let's jump into today's
conversation
[Music]
welcome back to the youtube made simple
show my name is heather torres and i'm
your host and i'm excited because i'm
joined by rob from raw build over on
youtube we're in a two-part series
talking all about how he went full-time
on youtube last week's episode was all
about his five pieces of advice for new
youtubers and today we're talking about
how he took the plunge and went all out
and all in on youtube so rob welcome to
the show
hi oh my gosh long time no see
i know we're actually recording this
just back to back i didn't change my
shirt that's like youtube 101 wrong oh
man
usually i have like a stack of outfits
where i just change from a black shirt
to a white shirt to a gray shirt it's my
color palette for everything and
they get black on black today so that's
what they get i just want to say i'm
glad that you got the memo uh black long
long sleeve so matching very nice very
nice yeah yeah i sent rob a text first
and i was like please make sure that
we're matching on camera today and he
said okay no so rob for the people who
don't know you yet tell us about your
journey of how you got started and uh
and what you're doing on youtube
yes so my name is rob and i have a
channel called raw built
r-o-b-u-i-l-t a lot of people think it's
row built
it's not it's raw built like my name rob
built something
and i've been to youtuber now for i
guess about 20 months now going on 20 21
months somewhere in there and i i was a
full-time copywriter for eight nine
years and just spent like anything any
word that you ever saw in ads i wrote
scripts i wrote tweets for car companies
for alcohol companies for sports drinks
companies so i was very involved in the
world of marketing before i ever started
a youtube channel which definitely like
helped me out a little bit in terms of
critiquing my own work and
self-awareness and everything like that
but yeah in the 20 months that i've been
a youtuber i've effectively i've gone
from zero to about 120 000 subscribers
and you know it's really cool that i get
to
say that youtube is my job uh it's one
of my jobs but it's my favorite job
yeah and we're going to dive into that
because a lot of times people think that
full-time youtubers means that actually
the only thing you're doing is youtube
and that's such a misconception that i
want to debunk um on the show today but
let's go ahead and take it back a little
bit um you just mentioned you are
working a full-time job while you were
building your youtube channel talk about
what that looked like um you know how
many hours were you working what was
that what what did it take to build to
be able to go full time
yeah i mean i
i started let's see i started my channel
in january of 2020 and that was when my
daughter was born she was born in
mid-january so i i chose the perfect
time to get started when i was so busy
having having a a newborn but
i did that for i would say
six months and really i mean it came at
a time during the pandemic and it was
kind of when coronavirus was obviously
like in its initial stages so we were
working from home and i really just got
to
uh like i had to make the best of that
situation which is really tough on on a
lot of people and not being able to work
going into the office like losing the
structure that was a really really tough
thing for me because i'm i'm adhd and so
not having
any kind of formal organization and just
being left to my own like
like
like schedules and routine not a good
thing for me uh but
i think i just i really found
that when i had a lot more time at home
because we weren't really working like
at the very beginning of like the
pandemic we weren't working like full-on
40-hour weeks just because everyone was
trying to figure out how to deal with
kids and you know daycare and all that
kind of stuff so we all got a little bit
of a pass at the beginning and so i took
that extra time i had and i just
completely put it in youtube and i was
like you know editing like my 15 minute
videos would take me about 20 hours to
edit 16 to 20 somewhere in there and
that was on imovie i mean imovie is a
relatively simple like a program but for
me it was just hard like i i'm not an
editor and so
i was just doing that like non-stop
every week
i was trying to do like two videos a
week and that that wasn't gonna happen
and you know just really really through
doing that like
i got really serious like i would spend
so much time just even outside of
content creation literally just watching
youtube like i stopped like the death of
team to of tv to me was when i started
my youtube channel because i just found
that i liked consuming youtube content
which arguably is work too you know like
as much as i enjoy watching youtube
content really i was studying youtube
content for a very very long time and so
it was pretty tough i mean i think that
my my job
like the people at my job were very
supportive
and i already had the side business of
airbnb at the time
and like i would always get asked
questions at work like why why are you
why do you still work like that this
doesn't make sense don't you make a lot
of money on airbnb and this and that i'd
be like well uh i make okay money but i
reinvest it and then youtube happened
and they were like you know why isn't
rob why is rob always late to meetings
or why did rob missed this leading or
why haven't we gotten this headline from
him or whatever but i had a really good
rapport i had been there for four years
and so you know they i my bosses were
great and they were just like it's all
good you know everyone gets a pass in
this time
and so i just spent like like i as my
youtube career really started to take
off and my subscribers started growing
it was like almost like we didn't really
talk about it at work but people would
check and be like yeah i saw that that's
like crazy
and you know um i tried not to talk
about youtube at work as much as i could
just because
a i mean it was always like in meeting
settings or like on group calls and i
just don't want to like talk about it
and like
i don't want people to know
how serious i was about youtube and how
much time i was putting into it because
i didn't want to know that that was the
reason that i was sucking at my job you
know and so i would like anytime someone
would ask them about youtube i'd be like
hey whatever happened to that you know
dog you got or whatever so
um so it really all started to kind of
really ramp up during during the
pandemic and you know i'm very thankful
for that i i again it's a tough time but
for me i just wanted to really try to
find a silver lining and my silver
lining was i got to start a youtube
channel my daughter came
right around that time and it was just
my time to really be around family and
be a youtuber and still get paid at my
job and not get fired and um it worked
out so
you know i did that for i quit like five
months ago um in back in march amazing
so all of that started really because
you had acquired a skill and i think a
lot of times people that are coming to
youtube um if they're just coming and
they don't quite know yet what they want
to do or what their channel should be
about i think there's a
harder learning curve but you are
already in the airbnb space i mean you
had built this tiny home in your
backyard you were house hacking i know
this because i'm a fan of the raw bill
show or
channel um and so i i know that you were
already in a skill and you just started
by answering questions and showing
people what you were doing and helping
people understand what airbnb was but
you weren't doing this you know um
between the nine to five some of your
videos you were recording at like 1am
after your daughter had gone to sleep
and so talk a little bit about
the hustle that had to go into being
able to quit your job within a 20-month
period of time of starting youtube
yeah i mean that's definitely something
that i think
you know
like one 15 out of 15 minute video i
guess like honestly this i've always
heard this stat and now vocalizing this
it makes a lot of sense but like one
15-minute video is generally anywhere
from 14 to 20 hours of editing time
that's what the professional editor like
i have a full-time editor that works for
me now and he's a good friend he's a
friend before an editor caleb if you're
watching this you're the best um but
like
a lot of time goes into that not just
the 15 hours that goes into editing it
but also like you know the two or three
hours or four hours that it takes me to
record it and yeah like most of my
videos i thought when i became a
full-time youtuber you know i was like
oh i'm going to be full-time i'm going
to be recording content at like noon on
monday on tuesday maybe i'll crank out
half a video on wednesday i'll do
another half i'm going to be so ahead of
thing maybe i'll do two videos a week no
that is not how that works at all most
of my videos get recorded
around midnight like the last video that
i recorded i ended at 2am
not because i want that it's like the
worst time to do to do that kind of
thing but for me like
it just with all the different
businesses that have kind of come to
fruition because of youtube and because
of how my lifestyle has changed like it
is the only time that i have to do it
and
generally speaking i would never do
anything work-wise at that time but i
just i love youtube so much i love what
it's done for me that you know like i'm
willing to put in that work and a lot of
people see a 15-minute video but they
don't really understand that like it's
like it can be dozens of hours sometimes
uh you know for like i just i released a
40 minute video a couple months ago
man just to review that is like an hour
just to like watch it through right
because i stop and then i think about it
and i might write a comment but like it
takes a lot of time so thankfully for me
i really love youtube and it's really
created a lifestyle for for me and my
family that i'm very thankful for um
because while i make money on youtube it
really feeds into
like all of the other things that i have
going on in my life from a financial
standpoint
yeah we're going to talk about that
because that is such the tip of the
iceberg right youtube is really the
casting the net and then bringing in the
fish and this is all the businesses of
the opportunity that comes being
consistent on the platform here at think
media we teach that you should be at a
certain threshold before you decide to
go all in on youtube and you were smart
by building multiple streams of income
it's not like you were just reliant on
the adsense but what was the threshold
for you and your wife to really say no
i'm ready to quit my full-time
six-figure job to make this a reality
over on youtube
yeah totally so i guess just to like
provide some context my salary as a
senior copywriter at my agency was a
hundred and ten thousand dollars
and my wife's salary was eighty eighty
thousand now like seventy five total we
made 185.
uh math is not my strong suit but once
185 was like our total
and because of what youtube created for
me
and the way it just like
propelled my financial situation and
just like the support that i got from
people i decided to do this crazy thing
and leave my comfortable house in
l.a
and uh moved to the middle of tennessee
in gatlinburg we bought 50 acres we
bought a house and i was like i'm going
to build a tiny house village
and you know it was a really big bet
that we took and in order to do that my
wife was going to have to leave her job
because she's a teacher and you know
that i i always like
appreciate that she was willing to do
that for us because like you know she
was like follow your dreams let's do it
and she supported me and now what now we
lived out here so it was actually fully
my intention
when i moved out here to move out here
in like december and then go back to la
and work like in june or july that was
always my intention
and that's why i told my company was
like hey i'm moving to tennessee
i'll be back in july and they're like
great sounds good that's that's really
cool good for you and when i got here i
just really i started to to math out
how having a
185 000 lifestyle was actually holding
me back financially
in some pretty significant ways um
because like that's a good salary like
that's a good living that was the first
time my wife and i were like we did it
like we're like we're not broke anymore
you know and we lived in california so
obviously it's not like as good as other
places but for us we were just like this
is awesome let's go eat sushi right
and um that comfortable lifestyle
was very difficult to leave because we
had full-time health insurance
we had like benefits 401k
and really i just kind of had this
moment in like
it was just there were several moments
but there was this one week where i
spoke to like three or four different
people a couple of different youtubers
a couple of different friends who are
entrepreneurs of companies
and they were just like we were zooming
and they're like hey
why do you still work by the way and i
was like what do you mean they're like i
know how much you make on youtube i know
i know how much you make on airbnb like
i don't understand why do you still work
a nine to five
and i was just like i don't know because
i'm scared but like those conversations
really had an impact on me because it
was the first time that someone
really kind of just frankly asked me
that and it happened to all be in the
same week and i also saw a couple of
youtube videos funny enough about
just like the the value of time and i
was consuming a lot of like millionaire
content too just because like i like
productivity and like personal
development and so
there was like these these like
different channels that were like here's
how i made a million dollars i cut out
this i cut out this i cut out this and i
just
got served up the perfect content on
youtube that week where i was like
huh that makes a lot of sense and it
happened to be
like in that week or the week after i
had those zoom conversations with
different people
and so i just really sat down and i
wrote
all the different scenarios what would
happen if i quit my job
uh worst case scenario here's how much
i'm gonna make
uh middle scenario here's how much i'll
make best case scenario here's how much
i'm gonna make and when i looked at the
numbers for all of those i was like oh
my god
every single one of these scenarios are
significantly more than what i make now
and funny enough i actually just mapped
this out and i'm actually at three times
the best scenario for this year and it's
because i was able to quit my job and
really focus on
putting a lot of time into all my
different businesses so what's the
threshold i mean i talked about this
actually in my upcoming video which is
probably out by the time anyone's
watching this but it's like one my
honest thoughts about quitting your
nine-to-five job and i personally think
it should be
you should consider it once you're
either making you should be making a
little bit more than you were at your
current job
because you're 1099 and you're going to
have to you're going to have bigger tax
implications there so you have to kind
of compensate that or
you should quit your job
whenever the side hustle that you have
literally cannot grow anymore without
you putting more time into it and that's
where i was at you know i was like i had
airbnb i had consultations at a
consultation service that i started as a
result
and
of my youtube channel and because like i
could literally not spend any more time
on those i was like landlocked in a
sense and so i was like all right the
only way i can grow these businesses is
by quitting my nine to five so i did
that and um
that was very scary for me uh you know i
cried i like cried like a baby to my
bosses i like
i set up a zoom i was like can y'all
talk and they're like what's up and i
was like
you know and they were like what's
what's wrong and i was like
i think i have to quit and they're like
oh thank god like you're you're okay
yeah yeah you probably do you should
have quit a long time ago like that was
like kind of the sentiment that was in
there because my boss was like are you
going to be like okay
like financially and i was like
yeah i'm going to be so fine here like
they're like all right then what's the
big deal like i don't know i'm just i'm
scared to lose the security um but it
was it was a tough it wasn't an easy
decision for me even though
i had already i was already making like
a lot more money like i started a
consultation service um
i just got so many dms and emails every
day that i was like well maybe i should
just like do a one-on-one with people
and i started out charging like 150 an
hour
uh and i was booked like it started off
as like one or two every single week and
then i charged 200 and then 250 and then
300 and then 325 an hour and it went
from being one to two a week to four to
five to eight to ten to being fully
booked a month in advance and then when
i ended all that i was charging like 500
an hour and that to me i was like this
is
exactly what i've always dreamed of
right like this is a lot of money i
don't have to worry about money as much
anymore and i had my salary
but then i really quickly realized the
hard way
that time i had no more time and
you know
sure i was making like a decent amount
of money from consultations and from
youtube and from like other like
affiliates and all that stuff
but i had no time to spend with my wife
and my kids and like that's like to me i
was like
what
i i have all i'm making money but at
what cost you know
and so that to me was one of those big
moments that i was like okay money is no
good if i
a live in the middle of tennessee really
can't even spend it there aren't like
stores that i can go to
but b
i don't even get to enjoy the the
amenities and the luxuries that it could
afford me with my family because i'm in
this office all the time
and so that was like one of the really
big decisions for me so if you're
thinking about quitting your
nine-to-five job do it but it's like not
necessarily rainbows and butterflies
like the video that i'm gonna release is
like you know it is a real video like
look it's great but you really have to
consider that when you leave your
nine-to-five job there are some
implications and you have to be ready
for it even if you are financially ready
for it but i want that for you i want
that for people and it's like it's such
an exciting thing i've learned so much
about myself
as a result as a business owner as an
entrepreneur and honestly as i always
say i'm i'm legitimately just honored
that i get to make a living
making goofy funny videos on youtube
with programs that teach people how to
start airbnb businesses and like to me
it just doesn't get cooler than that
it's so good man so the threshold for
you really was um
a couple things i'm so glad we're having
this honest conversation about this
because i think the headline of quit
your job or you know quit your nine to
five and make a six figure income on
your side hustle it's like okay and you
said a couple things one
the leaving of the security
of not just the salary but the benefits
and and and the structure and those
types of things that was a big thing but
then the time and i think as people uh
start to see you know um single fire
just released uh their latest report
that content creation is the fastest
growing small business type right now
what we're doing is the fastest growing
small business type and i think it has
so much unsecure things about it because
you're stepping into this new world of
entrepreneurship so if you have a nine
to five you're going from w2 into 1099.
now i don't want to go down this road
because neither rob or heather are tax
experts
or legal expertise um true books is who
we use um
we like them and uh and so we have
someone on our team that is that is
helping with that i don't want to go
into it too much rob but it is those two
things the time and the security so i
want to like shift focus real quick
because now that you've quit your nine
to five um you're making your own
schedule as an entrepreneur you're
making more money than you've ever made
and your potential is only to increase
from here because of the opportunities
that youtube has provided let's go to
break down a couple of the different
revenue streams and really all of these
stem from the influence and the personal
brand that you're building off of your
youtube channel
totally yeah i would love to so
you know for me uh
just like in
and thankfully actually funny enough in
2020 that's when i started my
consultation business and i made 25 000
just by kind of casually doing these
consultations on the side and i say
thankfully because the the merchant so
for those of you that don't know when
you become 1099 you can't necessarily
use that as your income if you're trying
to qualify for a house or any kind of
like loan investment type of thing
and that's a very troubling thing for
someone that's like a real estate
investor like i make my money off of
real estate investments and so you
really need that 1099 income for two
years on your taxes before bank says
okay yeah that's like this makes we
believe you you make money here's your
house like it's very very tough so
thankfully i had started my my
consultation service in 2020 which is
stripe
the the merchant the the credit merchant
and so that's all my taxes like striped
paid me but really when it's all ramping
up for me here in 2021 it's the same
merchant that really
pays me and so i'll be able to average
out like both years and use that as like
income for myself so i'm getting through
the 1099 hurdle and there are things
that i'm going to have to do from a tax
perspective
from a filing standpoint that i'll have
to change up but
here's kind of how things really shifted
for me and and changed and evolved and
all that stuff so as of today
i'll look it up here but in my first
year as a youtuber uh from
june 6th uh to june 6 like 2020 2021 i
made 40 000 on youtube
which to me was like you know i was like
let's go i was like so excited i mean
obviously one would want more but for me
i was like come on this is like i really
can't complain about that at all like
it's amazing you're one rob for your one
like imagine you're five and ten okay
that was number one okay keep going
that was like i got really i it was
crazy because my first month all right
so like i always say this like my first
goal on youtube i wanted to make it i
wanted to have a thousand subscribers
and i hit a thousand subscribers on june
6th oh no sorry june 18th and i hit the
4000 watch hour this like that day or
the next day
and so
i was like oh my god like that's so cool
and i was like so excited and then i got
monetized and i was like all right i'm
ready for like eight dollar you know
eight dollars a month that's one
chipotle burrito
and
on july
20th or something like that like just
under a month uh later somewhere around
there youtube made me a crater on the
rise
and that they basically featured me on
their on their homepage for a day and
that was like a life-changing day for me
but on that day i made 1400
and that was like crazy on adsense but
for that first month that it was like
monetized i made like sixty seven
hundred dollars on youtube and i was
like oh my gosh and i remember like it
was like 400 a day a couple days in a
row and i remember like
texting my friends i'm like i can quit
my job i can do it i'm making 400 a day
that's not how the youtube algorithm
works you don't make that every single
day and in fact most of the days you
don't right so
you know there are some like learnings
there with the youtube adsense but fast
forward to today i mean
really it that was like my pinnacle and
then i basically went down to two to
three thousand dollars a month for a
long time and three to four and then
four to five and then i was consistently
making
five thousand dollars a month
for like the last six months or so but
this last month in august was my biggest
month ever i made i think eighty four
hundred dollars in august i got like 12
000 subscribers there are a few things
that happened for me that really caused
that catastrophic change from like 8 400
to like 5 000 i was on the bigger
pockets podcast i was on pbs like i did
a mini dock with them and a few other
little cool things that happened all in
the same month so i don't know what i'm
going to make now but it does look like
my average is gonna be about seven
thousand dollars a month so about eighty
four thousand dollars a year
is what i is what i think i'm gonna make
on youtube we'll call it 75 it'll
probably be somewhere around there
but um that's just one part of it that
is the very beginning of where my income
really comes from i'm also a guy that
teaches about airbnb and how to start an
airbnb business right and so because of
that anytime that i'm ever like hey if
you learned something from this video if
you want to be a host sign up with my
link down below and i can i'll be their
ambassador and airbnb actually pays me a
commission
just on that it's like a
like it's
it's a very very good commission but
just in the last six months
roughly speaking
i think i've made about eighty thousand
dollars
i've made seventy nine thousand nine
hundred and forty eight dollars on
airbnb affiliate commissions like in the
last like six like ninety percent of
that has been in the last six months
amazing so now we're at like uh 150 just
in those two buckets right there but i
also have brand deals too
and
so like in my first like
i guess like i really think like things
start to change like once you hit about
50 000 that's where like a lot of my
brand deals started coming in
but
you know in that first year of
monetization i made about 25 000 off of
brand deals
um so right there i'm at a hundred
thousand dollars just on youtube income
between like what i probably will make
with brand sponsors and all that and
that's really my first go at brand
sponsors i imagine this year i'll
probably make like 50 000 on brand
sponsors because i'm just growing at a
much larger rate now
so really again this is just surface
level i had my console my consultation
business i shut that down even though
you know it was up to 500 an hour and
you know a lot of people were like dude
are you dumb and i was like well it's
impossible for me to scale up
at that point and so i decided to start
a program where i taught people how to
start a glamping business and i also
just launched a program
where i teach people how to start an
airbnb business and it's a six-week
all-intensive program i have like 80
videos they're all edited in the raw
built style so like kind of fun and
quirky
and i also have
weekly live coaching calls i bring in
guest speakers i mean it's like a full
on thing
and just from those two programs like
from the two launches that i've had
you know um i'll probably i'll probably
be at like
1.1 million dollars just from that and
then that's like where i'm at now by the
end of the year
after like kind of launching more
evergreen programs and stuff like that i
predict that you know before december i
should be at about like 1.4 million
dollars just from the educational
content uh that i put out there so
between educational and like youtube i
like 1.5 or so
and honestly i've i have this math out
somewhere else but around here and then
i also have my airbnb business that
gets a little bit of a bump from from
youtube as well um because like a lot of
people want to stay at my tiny houses
and stuff like that i make about 25 000
a month from that as well um so i guess
that comes out to like 300k a year that
i make off at airbnb
so when you put it all together um
365 days from now i should be at like a
one point
i don't know this is kind of weird to
say out loud honestly like 1.5 to 1.8
i'll be somewhere there million from an
income standpoint
and i could not have done that without
quitting my full-time job and that's the
crazy thing i do want to reiterate
that's not necessarily going to happen
to everybody i've just been
incredibly lucky and you know
i
i'm like worked hard you worked hard rob
you worked hard yeah i did i did it's
like luck and hard work they really you
know they come at they have to be there
together i feel like you know it's like
for me i always say it's like
like 90 percent
90 talent
no 90 luck 10 talent and then it flip
flops to like 90 talent and 10 luck i
don't know if i really believe that
anymore that was that used to be like my
go-to
because now it is hard work like now it
is
100 hour weeks i'm trying to i'm not
doing that anymore now i'm like probably
to 60 hours but i'm really i'm trying to
get it down to like
30 hours a week if i can and you know it
it was hard to get here
like it wasn't hard it was hard work to
get here what i do
is not complicated it is not engineering
it's not rocket science but it is hard
work um and i do have to work my butt
off to to do this and to to make content
and to create programs like when i
created my airbnb program i mean i was
recording legitimately from like
11 p.m to 3 a.m
for like a month straight like i would
be bummed because like my business
partner my wife would watch movies like
my kids were you know like well actually
my kids were asleep but sometimes they'd
be up like if i had i have a lot of
people come in and out of my house all
the time just because like you know the
nature of how close we are with their
friends and they all get to watch tv and
hang out and i don't and it bums me out
sometimes because like it's 11 and i
just want to go like play mario golf
with like you know my wife or whatever
but i have to like record and so
it is hard work
but i'm so grateful to even be able to
put in the hard work and get the output
that i get
so good yeah so
a couple things and if you want to learn
um kind of how rob was able to do that
we actually teach that inside of our
think inner circle we have a 10-step uh
program where we teach people how to do
what you did rob you said actually the
biggest part was your course creation
and we actually teach youtubers how to
create courses inside of our think inner
circle so if you want more info you can
go to think innercircle.com uh just
wanted to let people know that rob but
you are so talented in and really i'm
i'm grateful that you're just a youtuber
who took the leap because holding back
from that security right and and holding
on to that 40 hour a week job um once
you stepped out of that
wow you went from 100 000 to over a
million
incredible to see and this is just the
beginning so just as inspiration for
those watching the show right now i just
want you to know that you know all of
this takes hard work all none of this
happens overnight um rob was building uh
you know actually physically building
tiny homes and building us
in the background as well as creating
content weekly that is amazing content
so if that's something that inspires you
and you want to do that my best advice
and rob probably is the same is you got
to just put in the hours you got to put
in the work and you'll see the fruit of
your labor but it's just like planting a
seed you've got to plant the seed and
it's going to take time it's going to be
under the soil no one's going to see it
and then it starts to pop up and then it
starts growing and when rob is able to
quit his job and actually go full time
into youtube and entrepreneurship is
when he actually saw not just his income
but his whole lifestyle change so rob so
excited that you were on the show today
um you can catch this two-part series if
you did not watch the first part about
his advice for new youtubers make sure
you watch that if you want more info
about the think inner circle you can go
to think innercircle.com
and rob where can they follow you if
they want to be a part of the uh rob
built do you have a name for your tribe
we're still trying to figure this out
too we're at like 2 million we don't
have a name for our for our tribe but do
you have a name for your your uh
community your fans yeah originally it
was the raw builders um but now it's
just the rob mob the rob
there you go if you want to be a part of
the rob mob where can they find you
yeah so they can obviously go to my
youtube channel raw built
r-o-b-u-i-l-t
i'm also on the gram uh same thing bra
built there and then you know if you
want to see me like you know
fumble and try to figure out like tick
tock you can also follow me there it's
rob bill toe same spelling except
someone i had to add an o because
someone took rob built for me so that's
the fun part of being a youtuber is now
i have to like
try to snag my username anytime any new
platform is out there so
yeah that's the secret hack no one knows
about like once you've already made an
uh
an influence in some category anytime a
new platform comes out just sign up and
sign up with your names yeah exactly
awesome well thank you for being a part
of the show today rob we'll catch you on
the next episode bye
are you ready to start or grow your
youtube channel do you feel stuck and
need help connecting the dots
join this free web class where you'll
learn the step-by-step playbook for
youtube success we've helped thousands
of purpose-driven entrepreneurs just
like you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com
you